something
hey everyone this is GQ recommends and
today we're going to talk about jewelry
and how we style it
we wanted to talk about jewelry because
as you might have heard we're currently
in the midst of a men's jewelry
Renaissance there's a ton of different
options out there across a wide array of
different prices and styles so even if
you don't necessarily think you're a
jewelry guy chances are there's
something out there whether it's a ring
a bracelet maybe even an earring that
you're going to like
I really like jewelry because you can
add like a Finishing Touch to your
outfit there are a lot of Trends out
there and it's sort of like the wild
west really you can kind of do whatever
you want as long as you're showing off
your personal style it's a Choose Your
Own Adventure
my personal jewelry style it's pretty
scant it's pretty minimal it's usually
one necklace
actually usually just tucked in to my
shirt and like one ring both of these
pieces are made by a friend of mine
who's a jewelry maker her brand is
called Aveda Studio both of these are
silver I'm usually a silver jewelry kind
of guy not that I'm opposed to Gold but
because I tend to wear just two pieces
at a time I generally don't like to mix
it you you don't have to spend a lot to
get into the Jeweler game that's what's
great about say like a brand like All
Saints if you're out like looking for
vintage jewelry and you see a little
engraving that says 925 that lets you
know that that piece is actually
sterling silver it's a higher quality
piece of silver it's not mixed with
other metals it can be really affordable
I really like this piece actually sort
of pearls sort of like um a classic
military dog tag but without the dog tag
right around the hundred dollar range if
you have a little bit more of a budget
Maple Co is a really great brand
stylistically and price point wise a lot
of Great Value there some of the pieces
range from like classic Signet style
ring that's never going to go out of
style to something maybe a little out
there this guy is kind of a horseshoe
design with inset pearls you know I'm
not really a pearl guy but I actually
really like how they done that here
usually pieces float around like 200 300
something like that if you have a very
large
budget The Next Step Up would be
something like good art Hollywood this
is a brand that makes all their own
jewelry in LA in their Studios they do
it all by hand and it's top-notch stuff
this bracelet it's heavy not only is it
like pretty thick it feels weighty this
is the stuff you see like Sylvester
Stallone wearing apparently he's a
really big fan you'll see him decked out
in all that stuff which the style like
totally makes sense for a guy like him
I would describe my jewelry style as
extra
I got two pearl necklaces a biker chain
so this is like a pointy chain and then
I got a Chanel pearl necklace as well I
always like the idea Chanel pearls that
like Elegance of it this is like usually
what I wear on a regular basis when I
come into the office it's all on me and
then I got in my mouth I got a a grill
My Jeweler Elon from Gabby and Elon
jewelry are made my girl I have it in
sections I don't like consistent things
I wanted something that kind of stands
out when you see it you're not gonna be
like oh you just went for the typical
like rapper or so-and-so piece you said
okay now you put some thought process
into it and you did something different
that's what I did for this so it's three
it's two in the middle and it's all
three on the other side so if I ever
want to like exchange Parts I'm gonna
like add stuff in and out
in a celebrity world ASAP Rocky kind of
influenced my style from how I dress to
even meet the idea of wearing pearls
just being from Harlem me from my town
you want to be Jiggy like you want to be
fly like the idea of wearing pearls and
doing these different things is the
embodiment of Harlem seeing somebody
like ASAP Rocky going with with pearls
or with pink is groundbreaking is
defining new masculinity you dress how
you want to dress like you wear what you
want to wear you you put on what you
want to put on if it's fly to you then
it's flaw and don't care about what
everybody else thinks copy
there are a lot of cool Brands making
pearls these days and one of them is
fry Powers with this cool pearl necklace
this is really dope like this is really
rock star and then you add the grungy
element to it so you got two looks in
one this is also from fry Powers as well
if you want to take it to another level
you see the pink enamel it reminds me of
killer cam Dipset real Harlem stuff this
is really cool this is really dope if
you haven't caught any jewelry you're
still trying to figure out what to do
what my Lane is in this just start take
that step forward like
take the step forward and copy it cool
is what you make it so if you like
something and you feel like it's dope
purchase it
[Music]
own taste and jewelry skews towards the
classic with a little bit of Personality
mixed in I don't really want to buy
something especially if I'm investing a
significant amount of money in it and
then not want to wear it ever again in a
year's time the bracelet here these are
Japanese glass beads and freshwater
pearls this is from a brand called San
Angelo which is really cool and also way
more affordable than it should be
everything else I'm wearing right now is
vintage sadly if you're trying to buy
the exact same one this is a necklace
from the early 50s immediately post
World War II there is a Jewish star on
there that says xion which means Zion
this is an Omega watch that's really
small because it's actually a woman
style which I like I tend to gravitate
towards much smaller faces than are
popular right now I have three earrings
my mom is not happy about any of them
but I think this was my way to
compensate for a lack of tattoos I think
it's a lot more common for are meant to
have a single earring like some of the
ones we see here you might have caught a
glimpse of like a dangly pearl earring
on the person you follow on Tick Tock
various other influencers of the Gen Z
set I didn't really want to go for that
look I think it's very cool if you can
pull it off but this seemed a little bit
more discreet to me the brand that makes
the two necklaces furthest for me is Lu
it's a miami-based brand that Rose to
prominence because Harry Styles is a
huge fan but Justin Bieber wears them
all the time they're really cool and
they're they're pretty affordable given
the make and the type of construction
that they use they use a lot of
freshwater pearls which are really hot
in men's jewelry right now but they
don't usually do exclusively pearls they
usually mix them with a glass bead of
sort which I think has kind of this
crafty DIY vibe that feels like
something your best friend would have
made you at summer camp I think one of
the best parts about the men's jewelry
Renaissance is that there is this
explosion of kooky on a bad actually fun
jewelry and if that seemed like it's
tough to wear I think it actually pairs
really well with the more conventional
gold and silver jewelry that you might
be eyeing so maybe start out with
something on the Tamer side but then
don't be afraid to layer them and mix
and match
I think first and foremost I'm a watch
guy that's the number one thing I don't
leave the house without I've always just
hated having like bare wrists as a kid
and then I started stealing my dad's
watch in high school and doing like a
two watch thing which was a look that
didn't work out but a few years back I
was looking for like a new brand to go
to my boy Nate put me on to William L
it's this brand that started from the
one of the head designers of uh long
jeans I always wore chains as a kid I
had the gold cross that my mom got me 10
years ago I started trying to search out
what I wanted to start wearing as an
adult I landed on like just the Classic
gold rope which is something that kind
of never goes out of style the first
rope was really long which made sense at
the time but then obviously if you look
at like hip-hop culture and rappers now
chokers have become the thing I
definitely want to shorten it a little
bit so this chain is my first chain
shortened and then because I'm OD be
skinny there's like some left over so I
got a second bracelet here and then I
started adding pendants to the mix so
this one not a big astrology guy but I'm
a Leo you know I wear a lot of black so
the Onyx pendant always looks cool
offsetting that polos are cool because
you can kind of just like stack
everything and they kind of just lay
Tastefully under the collar on any given
day I'll go out with at least one or two
of the short ones and then one pendant
just depending on the fit and then just
a Cuban bracelet to kind of go a little
Tony Soprano with it Rings were kind of
like my first foray into new territory
the thing about Rings it's like once you
start with one it kind of snowballs I'm
probably gonna stop here I don't want to
go full like Mr T
a six piece is kind of a really
aggressive thing to wear if I'm not like
Travis Scott or anything so I came up
with the idea to just do this two-piece
thing that blends in almost
imperceptibly and I went to Gabby Elon
to do that uh they do everyone from like
LeBron to Pusha T to anyone like me who
walks in on the street I'm sure they had
a field day just doing this it's
probably like the simplest thing to do
so if you're thinking about getting into
jewelry the first thing to identify is
like which piece of your body to
accentuate first ask yourself am I the
watch guy am I a chain guy or dog tag
focused there and then you can build up
to adding Rings or bracelets it's cool
to find your personal style one piece at
a time
[Music]
I would describe my personal jewelry
style as a bit eclectic definitely
sentimental and I like to mix Metals I
don't think there's a rule to mixing
Metals I would say honestly if you're
considering it to find like a sort of
like hero piece that has both metals and
then from there you can kind of go
anywhere with it for me it's this watch
that was my dad's it's a Movado vintage
it just has like really prominent notes
of gold and silver I feel like that kind
of gave me the permission to start just
kind of like mixing different pieces
together today I'm wearing a pretty good
mix of like what I generally like to
wear on a daily basis I have this ring
is from my grandpa he loves jewelry too
he was actually a jeweler in Ecuador I
have this piece that was from Chelsea
flea this I really love I got the Jade
ball at this Tibetan store and I went to
my jeweler in Chinatown and I had her
string it around a gold chain this is a
David yerman link bracelet that my dad
gave to me as a graduation gift he loves
your men and the this ring was from a
flea market in Argentina it was maybe
like seven bucks and it's solid sterling
silver but the ring was broken and so I
brought it to My Jeweler and she just
kind of like welded it together and then
I also have these forever link bracelets
from Cap bird and they weld them on you
so you can't take them on or off for
someone who's non-committal doesn't
really give me a choice one is really
dainty and gold and the other one is a
little thicker in silver but it has this
gold charm on it so again mixing Metals
some of my personal favorite jewelry
Brands Bernard James has really
beautiful fine jewelry super talented
based in Brooklyn has been at it for a
while I think he balances really nicely
this like femininity and masculinity in
his jewelry this black diamond tennis
necklace from Bernard James to me kind
of like exemplifies that perfect balance
of their black diamond so you know they
don't have as much of a sparkle but they
still have like a nice touch when they
catch the Light the diamonds are small
enough you know you can stack it with
another personal gold chain like I have
here and it won't take up too much much
attention if you will another personal
favorite is pearls for example we have
like a very classic round Pearl example
here from polite worldwide really
beautiful really classic and what I
personally would do to kind of like mix
it up a bit combining it with this piece
from BP Bella who's a close friend of
mine based here in New York she as you
can see here has mixed like traditional
white pearls with gray pearls which I
really love it's like my Pearl version
of mixing Metals I guess if you're
curious about exploring jewelry and you
don't really know where to start I feel
like mixing the sentimental and the
thrifted with like the pieces that I
bought adds like a nice unique angle to
your personal style so we hope you
learned something today if you liked any
of the jewelry that we talked about they
are in the description below and we'll
see you next time
[Music]